le feu
secteur difficile c'est un ampleur qui
n'était pas attendu hier et c'est ce que
justifie cette évacuation là
déclare l'état d'urgence plus de 4000
personnes sont dans l'obligation de
quitter leur résidence dans trois
secteurs de la ville
au nord à une vingtaine de kilomètres
deux brasiers pourraient fusionner
[Musique]
complète de la ville de Sétif on ne
prévoit pas d'autres évaluations pour
aujourd'hui il y a également des
pompiers qui arrivent en renfort ici au
total on parle d'environ 70 pompiers qui
seront à cette île ce soir et demain
pour protéger entre autres nos
infrastructures névralgiques en début
d'après-midi les évacués roulaient par
choc à pare-choc et de nombreux
résidences faisaient le plein d'essence
à faire on va être prêt la communauté de
Wasat mac-mani utenam a aussi ordonné
l'évacuation de 1500 personnes
Pessamit à 3 heures de route accueillera
des membres de la communauté
généreusement accepté de nous supporter
dans cette épreuve difficile et des
ressources il travaille déjà pour
coordonner l'hébergement des résidents
de Man
port quartier accueillera aussi des
évacués
ou le VR ou le fakewell puis venir à
Port-Cartier s'installer sur différents
stationsnements Québec interdit aussi
d'aller en forêt sur les terres
publiques dans plusieurs secteurs je
sais que la fin de semaine arrive
chassepage mais on en est au
villégiateurs de ne pas rentrer en forêt
pour permettre que le travail de la
Sauveur puis des intervenants puissent
s'effectuer puis si s'assurer de la
sécurité des citoyens la structure est
perterie plus de 120 feux en activité au
Québec près de 80 d'entre eux ne sont
pas maîtrisés on priorise donc 25 feux
pour protéger la population de nos
infrastructures des drôles
d'Hydro-Québec on aurait rapatriés tous
les effectifs de la surfeuse c'est près
de 400 personnes qui sont sur le terrain
depuis le début de l'année 320 incendies
ont été la moyenne de la dernière
décennie
en 94 appareil date ici Marie-Isabelle
Rochon Radio-Canada Montréal